good morning so this is a special honor
for me to introduce probably the
greatest team that science has known
Mike Brown and Joe Goldstein so their
careers are somewhat legendary in
medicine Joe's went to medical school at
the University of Texas Southwestern
Mike at the University of Pennsylvania
they both met at the Massachusetts
General Hospital as medical interns from
there went to the NIH actually Joe then
left and went to Seattle Mike based on
Joe's recommendation went to
southwestern and then they met again in
southwestern and they became one of the
incredible research teams ever the the
names Brown and Goldstein I was thinking
it almost seems like poetry they go
together so much the in Dallas
it was just Mike and Joe when you said
Mike and Joe everybody know there was
only one Mike and Joe the actually
during my years with them asked each of
them what it took to hold that team
together because everybody has said this
is the model of team science but
actually I'm not sure it's ever been
repeated even though it's the model Joe
told me it took a lot of attention and
that they were very careful if anyone
ever tried to give an award to one of
them without giving it to the other one
they wouldn't accept it the invitations
to various places very careful I asked
Mike what it took to hold the team
together and he said Joe
so the science is incredible so they
started off as MDS interested in
cholesterol metabolism and really wanted
to have an impact on one of the great
medical problems facing us they were
interested in genetics and identified
the LDL receptor out of that came
receptor mediated endocytosis and for
that discovery they won multiple prizes
including the Nobel Prize but their
career actually has been marked by
incredible science even since then and I
actually think the sterile response
element binding protein actually the
quality of science is probably as good
or better than the LDL receptor it
certainly is interesting and identifying
one of the first issues of regulated
intra membrane protein so the science
continues they've won together the last
reward that Nobel Prize National Medal
of Science and many many other awards
that I won't list but Mike and Joe were
a lot more than that - they've been more
than that to the scientific community
and they was certainly more than that to
southwestern they really helped make
southwestern I always viewed it as Don
Selden came there and really built him a
great medical school from almost nothing
and then he passed the baton to Mike and
Joe and they further built it and we'll
see who gets the baton next but you know
Mike and Joe would always come to my
office and say you know we need to do
this
you know southwestern has to do this and
and in all my years there that what what
I had to do was never for them it was
always for the school the it was always
they could never accept the thesis that
Harvard or Yale could defense that
southwestern couldn't do the that was
unacceptable anything that any school
could do southwestern could do and and
they achieved that and and they put
their time behind that when I had key
search committees Joe actually chaired
the cancer center search committee and
and Mike internal medicine for me and
and so that was incredible
so I they're a team and it's hard to
separate it but they're also different
and people always ask and you'll get to
judge who's a better speak or Mike or
Joe as you'll see they're totally
different but I don't know who's better
they say they have very different styles
Joe is is really has become the scholar
of science in the biomedical community
he's always in addition to doing his own
science he studies everybody else's
science and I remember in in my younger
days I had just arrived at Southwestern
I've been there a few years and Joe
called me up and had heard about this
guy Peter ah gray who had discovered
this water channel and he called me up
and said do you know anything about this
and I and this was years before Peter
got the Nobel Prize and and I said sure
I know a lot about it and so he said can
I come over I want you to explain it all
to me so I said sure so what I didn't
know is that before Joe came he read
every paper that Peter Gray had ever
written and he came
and there was nothing I could tell him
that he didn't already know better than
I knew which was typical and so Mike I
thought I'd share with you a story that
Mike and I worked together to work on
animal care at Southwestern and the
accreditation agencies basically were
upset that the mice that Mike and Joe
used were not completely free of viruses
and they basically wanted Mike and Joe
to stop their research for a year clean
their colonies and learn how to do real
research and Mike just could not accept
this he said this is ridiculous no one
has ever failed to reproduce anything
I've ever discovered and I'm not going
to do this and so Mike and I took on the
regulatory agencies and one of the great
accomplishments of my deanship at
Southwestern was to get our animal
program put on probation so with that
I'm going to just finish up by saying
one of the things I missed so much from
leaving southwestern were the great
scientific presentations that Mike and
Joe gave in tandem and and this was an
event that probably occurred once every
other year and and you are about to hear
it today
the and so it's it's really great to
turn the microphone over to Joe
so thank you very much Bob and it's
really a great honor for Mike and I to
be invited to celebrate the 200th
anniversary of this great institution
notice at the top the title says
surviving starvation but I could
actually give you a talk on surviving
life in Dallas without Bob Alpert
Albertan was so in our 40 years or so in
Dallas we've had many Dean's and I think
it's fair to say al pijn was among the
best if not the best and we even though
we say you said the Dallas could do
anything to Yale and Harvard could do we
couldn't keep you in Dowell so so we
lost out on that word anyway so in the
talk today I want to tell you about some
new a new area that Mike and I started
about five years ago involving on the
ghrelin growth hormone system and you
know many ways it was stimulated by the
idea that there's a changing dynamics of
chronic disease in the US and this shows
you data from the CDC over the last 60
years and in individuals over 50 years
of age and deaths from coronary artery
disease have dropped by 60% and this is
a result of people have stopped smoking
blood pressure has been controlled in a
way it wasn't early on and also there's
a decrease in the level of LDL
cholesterol as a result of primarily
statins and I will promise you that that
you will never hear the word C
cholesterol anymore in this talk that's
it
even though this is one of the few joint
talked to my thing I've ever given where
we have not talked about that particular
subject B that is in May the declining
coronary disease due to those three
factors plus actually aspirin therapy
too has to be added that is led to this
remarkable 60% decrease and an
epidemiologist decisions have predicted
that if if this continued in 30 years or
so coronary disease if this trend
continues coronary disease would be
relatively minor disease the problem is
as you heard yesterday
obesity is reared its ugly head and in
over the same 60 years
obesity is increased several-fold and
that has been associated with a marked
increase in type 2 diabetes in 1960 type
2 diabetes was a very rare disease today
15 percent of the population over age 50
or own anti-diabetic therapy for type 2
diabetes and type 2 diabetes and it's
insulin resistance are are really the
the underlying cause of what's now known
as the metabolic syndrome which is
probably the commonest cause of
atherosclerosis and coronary heart
disease in the u.s. today so it's very
unlikely that this trend will continue
unless something is done about obesity
and type 2 diabetes so that is the
challenge over the next 10 to 20 years
is to learn as much as one can learn
about the pathogenesis of obesity type 2
diabetes in such a way that one can
apply preventive therapy and the way one
is done for coronary heart disease so
here's how to famous artists have we
have viewed what's happened over the
last 50 years the swiss sculpted
Giacometti after world war ii looked
around europe and this is what he saw
and Lucian Freud the English painter
walked the streets of London
50 as later and this is what he's what
he has seen so there's our remarkable
evolution in the human body in just 50
years as a result of the obesity
epidemic so there's been a really I
think a very important start in
understanding appetite control and
obesity as a result of of two
discoveries that have happened in the
last 20 years so the discovery of two
hormones made in the periphery that
affect energy metabolism as a result of
action in the brain the first one was
discovered by Jeff Friedman in the
Rockefeller University around 1994
leptin is made essentially only in
adipose tissue
it acts on receptors in the hypothalamus
to decrease appetite body weight in
blood sugar and then about six years
later to Japanese scientists Kojima
Kojima and Kanazawa Osaka University
discovered ghrelin which is a
polypeptide hormone made almost
exclusively in the stomach and it acts
on receptors also in the brain several
places one of which is hypothalamus and
it has exactly the opposite effects of
leptin from pharmacologic studies that
I'll tell you about in a minute it
increases appetite increases body weight
and increases blood sugar so so for the
first time I think scientists have had
an entree into to studying appetite
control as a result of the discovery of
these two hormones and the fact that
they actually work in the brain and one
can now begin to set out what the
mechanism of action of these various
hormones is and there's a lot that from
friedman to work on leptin is led to
mapping neurons in the brain there's
less work on the mechanisms of ghrelin
and that would be
but my can I'll discuss today and this
is what sort of excited us about growing
so so we entered the field of ghrelin
fairly late so let me give you a
background of what was known about
growing up to about five years ago he
was discovered by kojima in Kanagawa in
1999
it's a peptide hormone 28 amino acids
produced in the stomach and only about
1% of the epithelial cells it's a
special type of endocrine cell and I
called Relan cells and it's produced as
a pre pro growing undergoes proteolytic
processing which I'll talk about later
and but this is a interesting aspect
that attracted our attention it's
modified by an oasis with an optimal
length an 8 carbon fatty acid this is
the only known protein in nature that
undergoes a modification with an 8
carbon fatty acid you've heard about
palm ventilation and Marisa Latian those
are much more widespread involved
probably hundreds of proteins but
alkylation as of right now the only
known protein is that undergoes that
modification is growing and the
optimization is essential for biologic
activity as as as reported in the first
paper announcing the discovery now from
human Kanagawa there are two forms in
blood ghrelin when we talk about growing
that we mean the optimal latent form of
growing the biologically active form and
then there's a soul growing and growing
without a bed yes and ghrelin but not as
a Silverland axon receptors in the brain
to release growth hormone and that's how
he was actually discovered as a growth
hormone releasing peptide here is
ghrelin this is a the form that
circulates in the blood 28 amino acids
and the optimal group has attached a
covalent linkage to the third a serine
is highly conserved in nature all the
way back to fish and the optimal group
all species of growling in and it's been
studied in fish and virtually all
vertebrates and the optimal group is
essential for them for the biologic
activity here's how ghrelin releases
growth hormone and this is a simplified
view of the subject but for the purpose
of the talk I think it's it's reasonably
accurate the stomach makes growling and
ghrelin can release growth problems
directly by acting on growing receptors
in the pituitary's of matter throws to
release growth hormone or it can act
indirectly on the same growing receptor
on the hypothalamic ocular neurons and
they're though once growing activates a
receptor in the receptors of classic
g-protein coupled receptor once it acts
on the receptor there's a whole series
of signal transduction events that lead
to the release of growth hormone
releasing fact then growth hormone
releasing factor has its own receptor
the gh RF receptor on pituitary some
autographs somatic close to release
growth hormone this is the canonical
pathway that's been studied for years
and it's been in all the textbooks of
endocrinology and the signal for the
release of growth hormone releasing
factor in the classic sense it's not
relevant it's actually dopamine and
other inputs from other neurons in the
in the brain and this is a pathway that
is responsible for growth and for the
classic actions of growth hormone and if
you'll see in a moment
ghrelin even though it can release
growth hormone does not affect the
growth banana so so these two pathways
and ghrelin works through its own
receptors and and one of it and let me
just say the physiologist who study this
believe that the major way in which
ghrelin is working is through this
pathway here even though this is how it
was discovered it was discovered as a
and tissue culture model on pituitary
ourselves a culture for building this is
probably the physiologic way which
growling releases growth hormone
so what are the functions of ghrelin so
here's how scientists have studied
ghrelin the first studies were the
examinations of plasma profiles
in animals and in humans and the
conclusion was that ghrelin delivers a
hunger signal to the brain and it's
involved in the initiation of meals and
this is probably the best study in the
literature about Michael thorne and
endocrinologist at the University of
Virginia and these are eight college
students who were put on a metabolic
Ward and they had three meals a day
while they also went to school and their
blood was made at every 20 minutes or so
and you can see that after they ate
breakfast the growing level came down
promptly and then an anticipation of
lunch it went up and then they ate lunch
and it came down and in anticipation
have done it went up and then it came
down and then when they went to sleep in
the middle of the night for something
that was dreaming without food the
growling level goes off and then it
slowly comes down but it never comes
down to baseline and maybe that's why
you wake up hungry and then you eat and
it comes back down so so in this studies
been repeated
humans and many animals and so this is
what led to the idea that ghrelin was
delivering a hunger signal to the brain
and then and then pharmacologic studies
were consistent with that in which one
could be minister XS ghrelin again to
humans as well as the animal's body
weight I'll just show you one study the
first one actually not the first but a
very nice one from Kanagawa and crowd in
Osaka in which this is the food intake
and majored in rats two hours after the
administration of ghrelin you can see
the food intake went up markedly and
then when they as control administered
as a sole ghrelin without often old
group even in a three and a half times
higher levels there was no big reason
and this study have been a thousand
studies in the literature beliar do not
in which ghrelin has been administered
to animals ranging from goldfish to cows
and in every study one always sees this
so on the basis of the the endocrine
profile attendant on the basis of the
pharmacologic data it would seem
reasonable to conclude that ghrelin is
an appetite stimulating hormone the
problem is when scientists began to do
gene knockouts on ghrelin gene and the
ghrelin receptor there was no obvious
effect on feeding only the normal diet
or on a own fat and rich diet and also
there was no effect on growth and this
is I think this is striking a result
because it would say that the effects of
ghrelin on growth hormone have nothing
to do here this was a surprise that
there was no effect of feeding you could
say these were all have so far gone been
germline knockout you could say there
the system is redundant this
compensation and but that hasn't really
been explored by doing a more selective
knockouts but be that insame
based on the data as of right now that's
a puzzle as to what is
normal function of growling since his
hormone and the optimization aspect of
it is totally conserved all the way to
fish so so about five years ago Mike and
I who had been discussing ghrelin after
the first papal because of this octenol
modification which attracted our
attention because we had a great tackle
this problem that we would approach the
growing catches the optimal group to to
grow and so this is the approach that we
decided to take and we were surprised
that the Japanese had basically made
every seminal discovery for ghrelin that
I actually told you about for all
practical purposes that they were
originating their lab we were surprised
that they had not reported this enzyme
so we knew was probably a challenging
problem and if you think about it it is
a challenging problem because if ghrelin
is made only in 1% of the cells in the
stomach the enzyme could either be made
only in those 1% or it could be a
housekeeping enzyme that could be all
over the body so will would one begin so
our as about chemists our first approach
was about chemical approach in which we
ground up we we scraped off that athelia
cells from the radioactive often the
Ocoee looking for the transfer of the
optimal group to to ghrelin which we
made a recombinant form of of ghrelin
and actually we had really successed in
fact was surprising it was too
successful we were able to purify a
protein to homogeneity and got the
sequence back they turned out to be
Marisa told Frank
the Ocoee Marisa transferase discovered
by Jeff Gordon many years ago turns out
to be a major enzyme in the in the
stomach and even though and the
specificity is not absolute so even
though we were using often the old co a
chemistry will never work we have to
have an alternative approach so with the
student jinyang who prior to working on
Relin he was working on trying to purify
these membrane proteins difficult to
purify and who's a smart student and he
said I'll work on any project he won't
be too but I don't know that but it's
gonna be really challenging and he rose
to the challenge
and so he came up with a violin thematic
and expression cloning approach to to
identify the enzyme so the idea was the
first thing had to do was to find
they did this processing and it so we
use this as a candidate in the
and then to be dadaism in time the
transfers to the long-chain fatty acid
to glycerol - I'm sorry
when is it secreted
of a secretely protein much like brother
that had a fatty acid attached even
though it wasn't he
no he told us this family of proteins
could actually work on some pretty
cooking so so getting Dallas went
through the mouse and the human genome
it came up
and then transfected those each of those
16 cDNA is together with CD knife of
pre-pro growing into these in different
processing cells functions work so this
looks simple and and this turns out to
be the right in time but let me
you should stop the project and let's go
on and either think about what we're
going to do sorry think about what we
were going to do whether we take a new
approach or whether we put jing back to
purifying membrane proteins so so that
thought came to him too and so while we
were out of town in fact i think we were
celebrating the 200th anniversary of
Dartmouth Medical School at the time
Jane decided that he could come up with
a cDNA on his own and to make a long
story short he actually using the
information in the genome from all these
different species for this particular
one he could not PCR he got four
fragments of DNA the whole cDNA was
about thirteen hundred nucleotides he
divided it into four different fragments
had those synthesized and then he pieced
them together by fusion PCR and
transfected them into cells and that's
what you see here but it turns out then
obviously after he got the right one
then he went back and was able to now
PCR the real one the annotation and the
genome was totally screwed up the first
two exons were missing and everything
but he was very lucky because even with
the first two exons missing with his in
thetic cDNA he was able to get the right
enzyme and then he could go back in PCR
and get that the true one so this just
gives you an example of a persistence
and perseverance and the threat of
having to go back to Farkle membrane
protein and if he had not done that we
would not be here today giving you this
talk so now let me call so much for all
the stories so we were able to show
there was in fact that the right protein
this is a hydropathy plot of of the of
the encoded cDNA and from the work on a
cat and egad it was known that these two
residues in this family where the
catalytic site so we were able to to
make a single amino acid changes in the
sea
and prove that in fact it was the enzyme
that was a formal proof towards the
right enzyme this shows you that the
expression of the the in fact we call
the enzyme both for ghrelin Oh a Sol
transferase the these are thin sections
of the stomach and this is a
immunostaining of ghrelin and shows you
that about one in a hundred cells and
the rabo probe disdained the goat shows
co-localization there's a virtually
identical co-localization between
ghrelin and go and when one does the
whole survey throughout the body it's
only expressed primarily in the stomach
just like goat there's a small amount of
expression in the pancreas just like
ghrelin and as a small amount and the
duodenum just like growing but 99% is
basically in the industry so the next
step in the in the study was to actually
get an in vitro assay everything up to
now had been done in and cultured cells
with transfection and so zinc in order
to gather the vitro assay one and headed
to figure out which form of ghrelin was
optimal ated and this shows you the
processing of pre pro growing this
because it's a ninety-four amino acid
arm protein the signal sequence is
clipped off and then one has what's
called pro ghrelin and then and this is
the processing of requires of action of
an endocrine hormone of processing
enzyme prohormone convertase one three
this is the same one that converts pro
insulin and insulin and and then you
have ghrelin and what gene found is that
the optimization occurs at the pro
ghrelin strain so for an in vitro assay
one made recombinant a pro ghrelin and
then use that in the assay and so the
assay that was the gene worked out was
to to infect insect cells with
baculovirus effectors encoding
the goats cDNA and then take those
membranes and this is a poly topic
membrane protein take those membranes
and incubate them with recombinant
programming there was that had a
histidine tag at the c-terminus and then
trigger a tadakuni okole playing the
five-minute incubation and then the we
actually makes you is placed over a
nickel colon and so that would so any
pro growing because of the hispanic you
late it would be radio labeled and that
was the kind of assimilation county it's
a very rapid assay and one has a very
low blank and then when when adds the
membranes from the cells have been
transfected with goats you see those
activity goes way up and then this is
the catalytically dead one of those two
residues to show that it has no activity
so with this assay one could begin to
look at the what what is the enzyme
recognizing what components of which
amino acids in goat is it recognizing
and we got a clue right away by just
looking at the sequence comparison of
all vertebrate relatives and you can see
that the first seven amino acids are
essentially identical in all growns
interesting the amphibian bullfrog in
the third position does not have a
serine has a threonine but it's still
all ace elated with with octa knowing so
so the idea what we decided to do is to
do it like an alanine scan of the first
seven amino acids make programming
recombinant lee and change each amino
acid individually to alanine in the
first seven positions and then repeat
the in vitro assay and see what would
happen when we did that this is the
wild-type activity changing the first
amino acid not that activity the second
one did not the third one knocked out as
you would expect because this is whether
our canola goes the fourth one not got
activity the fifth one small reduction
but essentially the enzyme seems to be
recognizing the first for the first five
amino acids and in fact we confirm this
in the cell based assay by making c
DNA's with each of these different
change amino acids and one got exactly
the singing wild-type one two three four
so it looks like the first four or
what's being recognized and we could
then formally show we could make a
either a pentapeptide or a tetrapeptide
and show that actually goat accumulated
either the pentapeptide are the other
tetrapeptide with the same affinity and
the same kinetics as with with the whole
pre pro growth so this gave us and
during the course of of these enzymatic
studies jing notice that the rate of the
reaction fell dramatically after about
seven or eight minutes was when here for
the first seven eight minutes and then
and drop so this suggested they may be
end product inhibition of the enzyme the
idea would be the adjutant formed put
the often yield growth group home progra
'ln that optinal group somehow inhibited
the the catalytic site of the enzyme so
we were able to test this in the
following way one to make these
pentapeptides
that had an optimal group attached
covalently and then add that in the
reaction where we're looking for the
ovulation of program you can see that
the ought to deal tenant peptide
inhibits the optimization of programming
and as a control if we made a tomatillo
into peptide 16 carbons that had no
effect in more stone had no effect so so
this suggested that there may be a
peptide automatic type of approach to
designing inhibitors of this enzyme and
so we were able to enhance the
inhibitory action of that pentapeptide
off into peptides I just showed you
right here this is a same curve
essentially the same curve I showed unit
lassen if we made one alteration in the
pentapeptide and that's changing the
serine 3 to a dime you know
which is a basically changing this
oxygen here to an amid and that enhance
the inhibitory activity about 45 fold
and then with that clue we enlisted the
collaboration of Patrick Harran who at
the time was a chemist and Steve
McKnight's department of biochemistry in
Dallas
he's a synthetic chemist and now he's at
UCLA but we've continued to work with
Patrick and he's now designed over 400
pentapeptides pepin/alma medics similar
to the adapt that I showed you and we
have several that have an animal of
affinity in the vitro assay and we have
one that works very well intact cells
with a inhibitory K I've about 2.5
Michael Moore so we're scaling up this
right here to do in vivo studies to see
what the effect of inhibition of the
goat activity is in an adult and to go
back to the questions whether it's
appetite alone are there some other
function that that ghrelin carries out
in the body so at this stage i'll now
will observe a moment of silence to
check out blackberries and I'll be happy
to take questions now and then Mike will
tell you what happens when one